[موسيقى]
ما هي الأجزاء البارزة في
هذا الاستاد في الواقع
التصميم الفعلي ومدى
ارتباطه بثقافة الأوبرا بألكرا المحلية ،
انظر هنا المدينة التي
اعتادوا على تحضيرها للغوص لصيد الأسماك
وهو السقف و  انعكاس
الحبل
[الموسيقى]
في عصر المخاوف بشأن
البيئة واستخدام الكثير من الطاقة
دون داع كيف يعمل ، يمكنك
رؤية الحجم الكبير لهذا الملعب الذي
لا نبرده حتى 1/10 من هذا الحجم الكبير
نحن فقط  رائع على بعد حوالي مترين حيث يوجد
الناس ،
نحن فقط نبرد على بعد حوالي ثلاثة أمتار حيث
يلعب الناس ، لذا فإن الباقي هو
كل ما كان هناك ، لذا ما نفعله هو أننا
نسحب على غرار غرفتك في الفندق ،
نسحب الهواء من الفضاء برده ، وأصدره
أندري  مرارًا وتكرارًا ثم قم بتبريدها حقًا في
كل مشكلة مرة أخرى ، تسمى هذه التقنية
إعادة التدوير
[موسيقى]